ja das ist ein bisschen unheimlich aber
vielleicht auch eine riesige chance
der zellbiologe bruce lipton aus den usa
ist davon überzeugt dass wir unsere gene
und unsere dna selbst in der hand haben
lenken können wir sie seiner theorien
mit hilfe unseres unterbewusstseins
demnach haben ist also selbst in der
hand ob wir krank oder gesund sind und
wie wir uns ansonsten entwickeln ein
hoch spannendes thema das ihr euch bei
whatsapp gewünscht habt und jetzt
bekommt in kriegs und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
zitat nicht die gegen gesteuerten
hormone und neurotransmitter
kontrollieren unseren körper und unseren
verstand und sagt laube und unsere
überzeugungen kontrollieren stattdessen
unseren körper unser denken und damit
auch unser leben ja diese aussage fast
bloß lippens verständnis zur
zellbiologie bestens zusammen er ist
überzeugt davon dass wir mit unserem
unterbewusstsein unsere gene lenken
können und ihr könnt euch vorstellen
damit widerspricht er dem großteil
seiner kollegen und kolleginnen
denn das langjährige dogma der medizin
lautet unser schicksal ist durch unsere
gene vorbestimmt schon in den 70er
jahren hatte bruce lipton mit seinen
experimenten an stammzellen erste
hinweise auf seine überzeugung gefunden
liebt als beleg dafür beginnt mit einer
einzelnen stammzelle in einer nährlösung
die sich alle zehn stunden teil nach
zwei wochen ist eine zellkultur
entstanden wenn man dort zählen entnimmt
und sind zwei neue petrischalen setzt
die jeweils eine unterschiedliche umwelt
für die zellen bilden passiert folgendes
in der einen schale wachsen zellen für
knochen in der anderen zellen für
muskelgewebe das einzig und allein
aufgrund der unterschiedlichen
lebensbedingungen die sie zur verfügung
hatten lippens fazit die zehen passen
sich ihrer umwelt an dazu lippen zitat
die dna ist nichts weiter als ein
bauplan was wir darin aufgezeichnet
finden muss nicht zwingend in die tat
umgesetzt werden
wenn wir mit einem bauplan unterm arm
zum architekten gehen nimmt diese doch
nicht dem plan dürfte ihnen die baulücke
und fertig ist das haus so geht das
nicht ganz im gegenteil jedes gen trägt
in sicht das potenzial aufgrund seiner
umwelt und der interpretation des
bauplans sage und schreibe 30 tausend
unterschiedliche proteine
hervorzubringen
das heißt wir gehen mit dem plan zum
architekten und dann geht die arbeit
erst richtig los ist wird angepasst der
plan wird modifiziert und auf der
baustelle ergeben sich fortwährend
änderungen demnach verursachen zellen
weder krebs noch hiv noch herpes die
jeweiligen zellen tragen lipton zufolge
nur eine tendenz in sicht dass solche
krankheiten ausbrechen könnten
falls man sich also mit dem herpes virus
angesteckt hat ist man infiziert doch
nicht jeder leidet
für immer an der krankheit bei vielen
bricht ist alle paar monate aus bei
manchen nur einmal lipton zufolge ist
der entscheidende verursacher dafür der
stress mit dem wir lieben doch wer ist
eigentlich der mann bruce lipton hat an
der university of virginia studiert dann
wurde er professor für anatomie der
stadt lange selbst im labor hatte aber
auch lehraufträge in er hat viele bücher
veröffentlicht und mittlerweile reist er
durch die ganze welt und hält vorträge
über sein denken doch was steckt
wirklich hinter diesen ansätzen die
allesamt schon fast spirituell wirken
fest steht als für etwa 18 jahren das
menschliche erbgut entschlüsselt wurde
dachten viele an das ende dieses
forschungsbereiches denn was sollte man
jetzt noch entdecken
doch mittlerweile ist umso klarer dass
der dna code selbst nur wenig darüber
verrät wie wir menschen zu menschen
werden ein anderer forschungszweig
blühte auf die epigenetik und hier
lautet die zentrale frage welche
umwelteinflüsse haben welche folgen für
unsere gene und wie werden sie dadurch
gesteuert und tatsächlich diesen
forschungszweig gelang es dann auch
mithilfe seriöser akademischer forschung
das dogma der medizin zu kippen die
eigenschaften eines organismus sind
durch das genmaterial das bei der geburt
vererbt wurde also eben nicht
unveränderbar bestimmt renommierte
forschungsteams weltweit konnten einen
mechanismus identifizieren der lange
übersehen wurde
unter dem einfluss äußerer faktoren kann
der zellkern regulieren wann und in
welchem ausmaß bestimmte gene aus und
eingeschaltet werden kleine chemische
gruppen heften sich an einzelnen genom
bereiche oder lösen sich wieder ab so
dass das markierungs muster des genoms
modifiziert wird spezielle enzyme lesen
es ab und sorgen beispielsweise dafür
dass gene eben ein oder ausgeschaltet
werden selbst subtile
umweltveränderungen können die
entstehung von krankheiten oder die
veränderung von persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
beeinflussen heißt also im klartext und
darüber sind sich heutzutage die meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
einig wir sind mehr als die reine summe
unserer gene verschiedene
umwelteinflüsse wie zb unser lebensstil
oder unserer ernährung spielen eine
wichtige rolle bei der steuerung unseres
erbguts und erst gerade konnte ein
forschungsteam der max
lang gesellschaft aus freiburg zeigen
dass solche epigenetischen informationen
wohl sogar vererbt werden eine studie an
fliegen legt nahe dass epigenetische
gedächtnis der mutter für die
entwicklung und das überleben der neuen
generation wesentlich ist dass anstand
wie gesagt von renommierten
forschungsteams sie ihre ergebnisse in
aussagekräftigen fachjournalen
publizieren teile davon gehen mit dem
denken von bruce lipton über ein
beispielsweise steht außer frage dass
rauchen das epigenetische programm von
lungenzellen ändert und das kann zu
krebs führen
der großteil der wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler dagegen würde
lippens theorie abstreiten dass man
allein durch positives denken
krankheiten ausmerzen kann das würde ja
auch bedeuten dass wirklich beten helfen
würde dass man sich geburt gesundbeten
könnte dazu hat dritten mal in einem
interview gesagt wenn ich meine augen
auf jemand richtet den ich liebe werden
lauter botenstoffen man gut
ausgeschüttelt die für mein organismus
vitalität und gesundheit bedeuten wenn
ich meine augen jedoch auf etwas richten
von dem ich mich verrichtet werden
stresshormone in meinem blut
ausgeschüttet und der einfluss dieser
botenstoffe bedeutet krankheit und tod
heißt also wir sind nicht opfer unserer
gene
wir sind stattdessen selbst für unsere
gesundheit oder krankheit verantwortlich
und ja auch hier würden viele
forschungsteams in teilen zumindest
zustimmen denn ja klar ein gesunder
lebensstil kann dabei helfen gesund zu
sein und es auch zu bleiben doch eine
hundertprozentige garantie bedeutet das
eben noch lange nicht und beten hilft
der bekanntlich wirklich äußerst selten
fest steht zudem bruce lipton bezeichnet
sich selbst als peter sentis er
bestreitet viele prinzipien der
genexpression und beruft sich einzig und
allein auf die regulation durch
umweltfaktoren und positiver gedanken
doch wir wissen alle
manche krankheiten sind genetisch
bedingt manche werden durch
umweltfaktoren ja einfach ausgelöster
kann man gar nichts gegen machen
die ansätze von linken sind sicherlich
spannend doch am langen ende sind sie
dann doch vielleicht zu kurz gegriffen
so oder so finde ich den ansatz aber
mega spannend wir können vielleicht mehr
beeinflussen als wir denken und wenn ich
mich so in meiner
umgebung umsehen dann bemerkte ich schon
dass bestimmte menschen eher leiden als
andere und dass sich eine positive
einstellung auch auf den rest der des
gesamten menschen auswirkt sicher hat
das auch wiederum wieder mit der
beobachtung zu tun wir dadurch auch
beeinflusst wir sehen positive menschen
natürlich positiv aber ich hab schon ein
wenig den eindruck dass die einstellung
und die lebensweise die positive
einstellung und lebensweise mehr
positive auswirkung hat als bisher also
wir bisher gedacht haben wenn er als
erstes neues zum thema zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
von kriegs- und mitmachen und mir themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei
pixum so passiert einfach hier auftreten
dann geht es automatisch weiter
natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
der glocke vergessen je hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
werden den soldaten jetzt realität
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran